[Music]
on this monday night historic balm
cyclone extreme weather hits the pacific
northwest of the u.s and canada
okay that's an eerie sound the tens of
thousands left powerless and the
destruction containing the fire on a
container ship off bc the fears for the
environment and the supply chain crisis
what's behind all the disruptions
facebook further exposed the algorithms
take people who have very mainstream
interests and they push them towards
extreme interests the new treasure trove
of internal documents leaked and a
spanish volcano's widening threat the
uncertainty for the people of la palma
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a bout of extreme weather
buffeting the pacific northwest from san
francisco north to the bc coast what's
known as a bomb cyclone a rare
phenomenon that rapidly intensifies and
this is one for the record books
in northern california it unleashed
heavy rain and strong winds water
replacing fires and drought and
triggering flash floods and landslides
in places where vegetation had been
burned away
an atmospheric river converged with the
cyclone toppling trees and knocking over
scaffolding in the san francisco area
power was knocked out to tens of
thousands of people
just crossing a bridge became a perilous
journey this semi was nearly blown right
off
and that howling sound is from the
golden gate bridge gale force winds
caused an eerie whistle that could be
heard for miles
near seattle the storm turned deadly two
people were killed when a tree fell onto
their vehicle
in british columbia it is the strongest
low pressure system ever recorded wind
warnings remain in place for metro
vancouver and vancouver island but it
hasn't been as destructive as south of
the border still ferries have been
canceled and crews are dealing with
power outages and downed trees
and the coast guard says the weather has
made it impossible for a salvage crew to
board the container ship that caught
fire near victoria some containers
continue to smolder about 40 others
ended up in the water and are drifting
in the sea some of them carrying
hazardous chemicals robin gill has our
top story tonight
anchored near victoria bc the mv zim
kingston is taking a beating from strong
winds hitting vancouver island
this is not the kind of weather the five
remaining crew members need when trying
to contain hot spots below deck smoke is
still present salvage master has stated
there are still pockets of flame and
some iso containers have internal fires
the weather is preventing firefighters
from getting on the ship to help it's
not clear how the fire started but it is
confined to 10 containers two tugboats
that happen to be there have helped in
the fight it was very fortunate
that these two large escort tugs were
here and were able to respond as quickly
as they did the concern is the
containers carrying over 52 000
kilograms of potassium amyl xanthate a
hazardous material used in mining this
continues to be a very dangerous and
difficult situation
the fire was the second spell of trouble
for this beleaguered boat sailing under
the flag of malta the 260 meter ship
left south korea for vancouver last
thursday it got caught in a storm the
waves were so rocky the ship couldn't
stay upright and 40 containers slipped
off in the big picture it's a very small
impact on the supply chain
yes is there a lot of cargo on board a
ship that size of course um will that
have impacts for people that are waiting
for that cargo yes and it's going to be
a lengthy delay nine ships enter the
port of vancouver on a daily basis more
than three million containers are
processed every year and imports to this
part of canada are up 18
over last year all that marine activity
has environmentalists worried the damage
is often under reported and
and it's it's
undersold to the public but it's it's
long-term damage both the american and
canadian coast guards are monitoring the
environmental impact and there are still
those missing containers to recover
robin gill global news vancouver
container ships are key to keeping the
world's supply chain functioning and for
months now that chain has been holding
together by a thread there are backlogs
of container ships waiting at key ports
and from rail yards to warehouses there
is gridlock tonight we begin a new
global news series called short supply
and gaviola explains what's behind the
delays shortages and higher costs
phil swanson lays fiber cables for home
internet in rural alberta demand is
still surging due to the pandemic with
people working and studying from home
but lengthy delays in importing product
mean he's racing against the clock to
install before the ground freezes we're
playing a lot of catch-up this year
because we did lose four months of build
season so
we're hoping the snow doesn't fly here
relatively shortly and shut us down
supply chain snarls have impacted all
kinds of things from cables to cars
appliances to halloween costumes there's
a shortage of microchips key components
in laptops cell phones cars and you may
have noticed some items especially those
which need to be shipped from asia and
europe are in short supply or missing in
action what we're seeing is the result
of a chain reaction caused by covid
factories have resumed operations to
meet demand as economies around the
world roar back increased covet
protocols mean shipping takes longer
because of new safety measures at ports
plus products that weren't in high
demand before like masks and other ppe
are now taking up room and shipping
containers the drury world container
index a global benchmark shows shipping
costs have soared nearly 300 percent in
the past year and there's another
important piece in this puzzle too labor
shortages which make it hard to staff
factories and ports we've really seen a
sustained
increase that doesn't show any signs of
slowing down we haven't even gotten into
shipping containers they're in short
supply too i've got people on conference
calls saying that there were times they
were paying 2500 or you know five
thousand dollars for a container and now
it's upwards of twenty five thousand
dollars
even though some ports in california are
working around the clock it is chaos the
biden administration is reportedly
considering enlisting the national guard
to reduce the backlog now once items
arrive onshore they need to be trucked
to merchandising centers but you guessed
it there's a shortage of truck drivers
too analysts say there is an end in
sight but not until halfway through 2022
when things are likely to get worse
ahead of the holiday season expect
delays shortages and higher prices donna
all right ann gaviola in toronto thanks
it is the eve of prime minister justin
trudeau swearing in his new cabinet the
team he's chosen to run the country we
know there will be some new faces
because some past ministers either
didn't run or lost their seats in the
september election and we know christian
freeland is staying on as deputy prime
minister and finance minister apart from
that there's lots of speculation abigail
beeman is watching this for us abigail
what's the balance the prime minister is
likely going to try to strike
donna there are a few elements at play
first the prime minister has committed
to gender parity and he has his work cut
out for him since he lost four ministers
all of them women catherine mckenna who
did not run again and two ontario
ministers and one in nova scotia who
lost their seats speaking of regions
trudeau is also going to try and balance
geographical representation in the new
cabinet someone to replace the atlantic
seat for one sean frazier and former
nova scotia justice minister lena met
legend a rookie mp are some of the names
being floated there and after being shut
out of alberta in 2019 the liberals
managed to elect two mps there important
to have some western representation in
cabinet at least one is likely to be
added between georgia hall and randy
bossino a former special adviser to the
prime minister those two are both men
which is where the speculation about a
bigger cabinet comes into play currently
there are 36 ministers plus the prime
minister if trudeau adds a man from
alberta he'll need to either get rid of
a sitting male minister or grow the
ranks to make it even as for the women a
wide range of speculation depending who
you ask there's a long list of potential
female mps who could be eyed for a seat
at the inner circles table
and abigail what's the thinking on which
ministers who were seen to be top
performers might be back and who might
be shuffled out of cabinet
well uh lots of people have eyes on the
defense file for one minister harjit
sajin has come under fire for his
handling of the number of misconduct
issues that have rocked the military the
conservatives today piled on putting out
a statement calling for him to be fired
there's a lot of talk about getting a
woman into that job anita anand seems to
be the top possibility she is seen by
the inner circle as a real star in
cabinet for her handling of vaccines as
procurement minister so in line for a
promotion a lot of people also watching
the health file hugely important of
course in the pandemic does patty haidu
keep the job it's a balancing act as to
whether to shuffle her out without
making it seem like the liberals are
admitting some sort of failure in their
pandemic response we have seen other
ministers active in recent days beyond
just deputy prime minister christopher
freeland who we know keeps her job we'll
see if there are shuffles at immigration
or environment with the cop 26 climate
summit looming ministers marco mendocino
and environment minister jonathan
wilkinson have been in the spotlight too
donna all right all will be revealed
tomorrow abigail beamon in ottawa thanks
saskatchewan premier scott moe is still
resisting putting in any more public
health restrictions he's faced harsh
criticism over his handling of the
fourth wave of covid19 for weeks
saskatchewan has had the highest case
and death rates of all the provinces moe
says he's optimistic the situation is
moving now in the right direction
about 70 nurses that are coming out of
out of uh training that will be
available in our icu departments we've
requested help from the federal
government they've provided about six
critical care nurses but ultimately uh
you know to your question the numbers
are decreasing they've been decreasing
since uh you know for about four weeks
now our numbers are down our seven day
rolling average is down about 45 percent
um that is a positive and that's an
indication that the measures that we
introduced are working
moe says most people are now fully
vaccinated and he says it doesn't make
sense to restrict everyone's activities
and personal freedoms
ontario and bc are lifting capacity
limits for those who are fully
vaccinated in ontario gyms casinos and
restaurants can now operate at full
capacity museums art galleries places of
worship and salons can too if they ask
for proof of vaccination and in bc fully
vaccinated residents can now enjoy
hockey games concerts and weddings at
full capacity there's still a 50 percent
cap on capacity in regions where
vaccination rates are lower
the vaccination rate among members of
the canadian military is over 90 percent
but the military has other problems it
has long struggled to boost the number
of women in its ranks and that's
especially true now as ross lord reports
allegations of sexual misconduct against
senior members of the military could be
having a major impact
ever since canada's high profile mission
in afghanistan created a surge in job
applications more people have been
leaving the forces than signing up a
2016 auditor general's report showed
numbers shrank from almost 68 000 in
2012 to 66 400 by 2016 and the decline
continues the forces recruiting center
in borden ontario says as of september
30th there are fewer than 65 000 regular
force members with an attrition rate of
between seven to eight percent a year
replacing those who leave the forces
with new recruits has been a losing
battle the military blames the pandemic
which made it tougher to process
applications not as much training was
happening so not as many positions that
we could enroll people into because of
the same complications but even
ready-made professionals are avoiding
the forces when the pandemic brought
commercial airlines to a virtual
standstill it opened the door for pilots
to defect to the air force this defense
analyst says fewer than a handful made
the jump the lesson for me is if you
couldn't get them if you couldn't get
them back in big numbers in this
circumstance then you are just utterly
uh in the hurt locker a high priority
recruiting target is also slipping away
increasing the percentage of women in
the regular and reserve force from 16 to
25 by the year 2026.
a goal some suggest has gone from
ambitious to impossible i'd be very
surprised if uh the current sexual
misconduct crisis didn't have a chilling
effect on recruitment especially with
women
in fact two of the forces higher-ups
forced to step aside lieutenant general
stephen whalen and vice admiral hayden
edmondson were in charge of recruiting
this is a challenging time period to uh
for the canadian armed forces like other
employers recruiting sessions have been
moved online
train for your true calling with the
canadian armed forces marketing messages
have not changed all of these factors
do not help
the current strain in terms of military
personnel and the personnel shortages
and it's one of many stressors on the
organization in this moment a new ad
campaign aimed at women was to have
begun this month it's been delayed so
has a new strategy for persuading
members to stay
as the military struggles to build for
the future while reckoning with the past
ross lord global news halifax
coming up the military seizes power in
sudan arresting the prime minister and
dissolving civilian rule
in sudan the military has seized control
in an apparent coup detaining the prime
minister and dissolving the country's
transitional government
protesters marched in the streets of the
capital khartoum and blocked off roads
doctors say at least three people were
killed and at least 80 others wounded
after security forces opened fire on the
crowds tensions had been building ahead
of a planned handover to civilian rule
the government has been led by a
transitional council made up of the
military and civilian parties since the
country's long-time autocratic ruler
omar al-bashir was overthrown two years
ago the military has imposed a state of
emergency its leader claims the
transition will continue and elections
will be held in 2023 but international
leaders are condemning the coup
in a statement canada's foreign affairs
minister mark garneau said we stand with
the sudanese people and their desire for
a democratic future
and a new report from the united nations
warns afghanistan is on the edge of a
humanitarian catastrophe the world fruit
program says about half the country's
population is facing food insecurity
without urgent action millions of people
could die of starvation
afghanistan was already facing a food
crisis before the taliban took over the
situation was made even worse when
countries froze foreign aid payments
according to the u.n report about 273
million dollars canadian in aid will be
needed each month to stave off disaster
the facebook papers ahead damning
documents shed light on the social media
giant's threat to democracy
we're getting the clearest picture yet
of how facebook endangers democracy
thousands of leaked documents are being
called the facebook papers and they
suggest the company knows its platform
is being used to spread misinformation
harm democracy and promote online
radicalization as jackson prescott
reports facebook insists it's not
putting profits ahead of safety but the
evidence suggests otherwise
facebook was built on likes and shares
and that may be its fundamental problem
they don't want to do anything that's
going to drive people away from
continually scrolling engaging with
posts and clicking and watching ads
thousands of documents released by a
former employee turned whistleblower
suggest facebook is acutely aware of how
its platform spreads misinformation
incites violence and radicalizes people
around the world the algorithms take
people who have very mainstream
interests and they push them towards
extreme interests mark zuckerberg has
previously called such claims illogical
but leaked documents show the company
knew of the rampant spread of vaccine
hesitancy in user comments the company's
internal research found that conspiracy
theories like q anon could be
automatically served up to a user within
two days of that user liking certain
content and more internal research found
a lack of local staff who could monitor
content in developing countries like
afghanistan
where most hate speech made it past
automatic filters i would say that
they're very well aware of the way that
their platform can indoctrinate and
radicalize people because this was a
study done by their own researchers that
has been replicated by people like me
yet the documents also suggest the
company faces an internal battle over
what to do about it i became convinced
that facebook was causing harm in the
world and causing division in the world
brian boland worked on partnerships and
product strategy at facebook he says he
tried to make change from within but
ultimately resigned i'm concerned that
facebook causes divisions in a lot of
areas political being one of them and a
powerful one that we feel viscerally but
also in race and ethnicity religion the
central complaint remains that the
company prioritizes profits over safety
in a statement to global news a
spokesperson refuted that the truth is
we've invested 13 billion dollars and
have over forty thousand people to do
one job keep people safe on facebook
yet the documents only add to the
growing pressure on the company to make
serious reforms or face stricter
regulation as government and facebook's
own users become increasingly aware of
the platform's impact
jackson proskow global news washington
a takeover of the island of la palma
next will the rivers of lava ever end
[Music]
the volcano on the spanish island of la
palma has been erupting for over a month
the slow-moving rivers of lava
relentlessly devouring everything in
their path thousands of people have
already been displaced more than 2100
billion buildings have been damaged or
destroyed and as eric sorensen reports
the volcano is far from finished
even from space it is a spectacular
sight to behold a window into the depths
of the planet that can reshape the
landscape overnight
up close it is menacing and
unpredictable the cumbre vieja volcano
on la palma is enormous since last month
the lava has covered nearly 900 hectares
and destroyed more than 2 000 buildings
most of the 83 000 residents are still
in their homes but the entire population
is nervous
he says we are thinking about this
volcano
how many weeks she says will christmas
come like this it is very difficult to
deal with
the volcano has been spewing lava for
five weeks and now has become more
active a secondary cone collapsed monday
creating a new channel of lava for all
that scientists have learned about
volcanoes they have made little headway
in predicting how long eruptions will
last
there is nothing to tell us that it
could end says this local volcanologist
there's no data to indicate that
volcanic activity is decreasing we will
have to see if it lasts weeks or months
volcanoes are among the most violent
features on earth and a source of
fascination through history it's at a
different scale from what humans are
normally used to dealing with
but it does give us uh insights into to
what's happening underground sometimes
volcanoes bring up samples
from 100 or 150 kilometers down beneath
our feet
for me scientifically that's why it is
so exciting la palma is popular with
tourists the volcano a favorite
attraction but now the streets are empty
tourists gone and some banana
plantations a mainstay of the economy
are being destroyed many many thousand a
thousand people they have lost
everything
house animals there will be much to
learn and to see here in the future but
it is when a volcano is at its most
visually breathtaking it's also the most
dangerous and the goal for now is
survival
eric sorensen global news
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is a shed near sudbury ontario
hey bud
you never know who's going to show up on
a saturday night this moose invited
himself over got a tap on the nose as a
welcome but when he tried to get to the
beer fridge they politely asked him to
leave
no way eh
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you